i saw this magazine cover just the other
day
gq and i see you on the cover and i'm
like this is fantastic
paul my friend paul is on the cover of
gq magazine
but then look look
and it took me like five minutes for
someone to convince me
that's not you that's chris pratt
that's absolutely stunning you look you
guys look so much like each other it's
uh in that picture even i see it a
little bit but
uh it's weird a lot of people said
you're
on the cover of gq i said i'm not and
then i uh and then i see press
yeah who's but a lot of people confuse
me for other people
is that true what do you mean you get
that a lot you get people thinking that
you're someone else
about two days ago james marsden
i don't mean to drop a name but he's a a
colleague and a friend
uh terrific actor yeah wonderful guy
yeah great actor yeah
sends me a hey he's all right
settle down i didn't want to get uh you
know come on uh but he says he had
an email saying i didn't know you fish
and i said i don't he said i saw this
picture of you
online and you're an angler
clearly send me a picture let's see the
picture i brought a picture here
wait
[Laughter]
[Applause]
so this is not you that is not me even i
had to take like a
triple take because it looked like me
right but it's not
so you were looking at that picture
thinking when was i fishing
and wearing europeans i had to like zoom
in on the face
and uh and it's not me and but the thing
that
really was confusing to me was what was
james marsden
looking at that's what was he searching
for that's what he
dug up what was he searching for yeah
fisherman
speedos plus speedos plus mahi-mahi
a common search uh and that guy is
probably somewhere out there like what
his picture's on this show yeah that's
weird that's right and he's not getting
paid a cent
sorry are you the kind of guy that would
wear that bathing suit would you would
are you comfortable with uh showing a
lot of skin i'm pretty comfortable with
showing a lot of skin but i don't know
if i'd wear that bathing suit i
there was about five minutes when i was
a kid
like junior high where all my friends
were wearing speedos
so i bought one but i wore it twice i'm
like nah i'm going back to the
clam diggers yeah i like as much bathing
suit on me as possible and you know what
everyone else likes as much bathing suit
on me as possible
the thing is is that my body is i look a
little bit like a thumb
in general i have kind of a your whole
body looks like a thumb i got like a bit
of a funny body what do you mean
i don't know i look like a thumb